hey everybody it's Charlie awesome news
we're bringing more Justice League
characters into the flash and arrow
verse this time it's through legends of
tomorrow so I'll explain what's going on
because it's gonna be black Adam Shazam
stuff there's a new round of the flash
ring giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber leave a comment
on this video but you might be familiar
with the ISIS character from the
Smallville TV show or the 1970s TV show
so legends of tomorrow is bringing the
ISIS character on as a main character
during season 3 she'll probably get her
powers from the amulet and I'll play
some of that Smallville episode because
it actually does a really good job of
explaining how her powers work it
references Black Adam so this is all
bringing the Shazam comics into the
flash and arrow verse there are a couple
different versions of her origin story
she actually started out and that
secrets of Isis TV show then that next
year in 1976 she debuted in the Shazam
comics and they changed her backstory a
couple times as things went along but
because legends of tomorrow is sort of
collapsing time on itself
we'll see how she pops up but the way
they describe her is that she's sort of
like this activist archaeologist from
the year 2030 so she's actually from the
far future in this final frame here you
can actually see a building from that
episode where they did travel to that
future timeline they haven't announced
who the villain is but just the fact
that they're bringing in more big
Justice League level stuff is so awesome
it's sort of like bringing Batman in by
doing all the Nightwing Titans stuff
even though technically he's already
part of the universe right now as far as
I know they're only able to reference
them in association so Batman exists
because other Batman related characters
that would not exist without Batman are
already on the TV shows so multiverse
theory it's all in there but on the
original TV show they never did an
origin story for her character but the
story was is that she found the amulet
of Isis on a dig in when she'd say I am
Isis it was sort of like her version of
saying the power word Shazam they would
activate their powers the way that Billy
Batson says it or the way that teth-adam
says it to become Black Adam the version
they're going with on the TV show is the
current version in the comics adriana
Tomasz but she actually didn't get that
name until the 52 series which was
around Infinite Crisis but then they did
one year later that's when they told the
story of how
she came to know black Adam how she got
her powers so in that version she was
brought to Adam in conduct as a slave
but he grew to love her he freed her and
then took her to the rock of eternity
Billy Batson had taken the mantle of the
wizard Shazam he grants a portion of
black Adams powers to Isis so that when
she says I am Isis she activates and her
powers work just like black Adams she
has a brother who's been oppressed for a
long time she tracks him down frees him
and then Black Adam does the same thing
for him he becomes Osiris the Smallville
episode does a really fun job of
condensing all this information whereby
Lois is possessed by the spirit of Isis
who's trying to resurrect Osiris there's
Easter eggs for The Wonder Woman TV show
the lasso of truth
you see Black Adam in there so here's a
condensed version of that I thought
those Sex and the City girls had gaudy
taste might tell that to its owner the
goddess Queen Isis she spent eternity
searching for the cut-up pieces of her
dead husband according to legend the
necklace is cursed
whatever soul dares possess it will be
condemned to spend all of eternity in
hell hey Clark do you remember when the
blur and I kissed how could I Lois I
wasn't there
I must locate the treasures of Isis he
said this knowledge was of great
importance
I'm the blur that is of no importance to
me the especial might have once been
called Lois but now it's yours Isis
[Music]
Isis I know how much you love Osiris but
you cannot sacrifice to us just to see
him again
with his body for your own and rise to
rule I totally miss Smallville totally
miss Erica Durance when she came on as
Lois she really turned that series
around for me she made it a lot more fun
but what legends of tomorrow will
probably do is give her a slightly
different origin story like I said it
sounds like she's going to be from the
year 2030 she'll be a rebel activist
like she was in the comics but she'll
find the amulet and that's how she'll
get her powers so as for the broader
Shazam Black Adam lore I don't know what
they're able to do what they're not able
to do but if Smallville is allowed to
reference teth-adam then that's probably
the way they'll use his name on the TV
show if they decide to use him because
in the Justice League DC EU universe
what they're talking about now is doing
the Black Adam movie first then doing
the Shazam movie I know everybody wants
army hammer to be Shazam but now it
sounds like what's going to happen is is
once they bring Superman back is that
Black Adam will be sort of a villain
that he'll go up against and it'll
present the need for Shazam to surface
so even though Billy Batson already
exists in the DC EU he just hasn't got
his powers yet or we haven't met him yet
if he has gotten his powers because
before Batman V Superman you have people
like the flash that already have his
powers but you don't really meet him
until Batman gets that file on him it
goes to recruit him so if you're
wondering who exists in the DC Universe
right now in the movies all those heroes
exist it's just that most of them
haven't been found yet in Black Adam has
been Black Adam for the last 5000 years
or so so if anybody exists it's him but
it'll be interesting to see how they
weave his lore in with the Amazonians
and Wonder Woman because they've been
around since the ancient Greeks but
Black Adam goes all the way back to the
ancient Egyptians so we'll see he would
be the oldest villain on the earth
depending on how you look at it but
what's happening is as legends of
tomorrow is still going to be Tuesday
nights after the flash as far as I know
it has not moved to Wednesday's episode
one is dropping October 10th that's the
second week in October so leave all your
requests for bonus videos they'll be
more flash arrow DC TV stuff happening
next week there's more Black Panthers
there's new Game of Thrones and just
because I was so bummed out about it I
didn't want to make a video just because
I feel like I couldn't get through it
but just wanted to say goodbye to Adam
we'll remember him forever he passed
away this week he had been such a big
influence on all of comic book TV movies
all the people that are making those
things nowadays he inspired so many
people he will be missed your orange
juice sir Batman special you interest me
strangely I accept your invitation
do we dare why not yes of course of what
use is a dream if not a blueprint for
courageous action show me miss Kitka or
I'll wreck this place with my dying
breath
you filthy criminals leave all your
thoughts about him in the comments and
while you wait for everything else to
post click here for more flash and you
can click here to rewatch that black
panther trailer thank you so much for
watching let's high five I'll see you
guys tonight